selon vous pourquoi la chanteuse Hoshi
a-t-elle fait parler d'elle cette
semaine
Sophie encore une transition de sexe
en permanence avec elle la pauvre c'est
exactement la bonne réponse
par rapport à toutes les menaces de bois
[Applaudissements]
partagé les menaces incessantes qu'elle
reçoit depuis maintenant 3 ans depuis de
nombreuses années aussi subit un
déferlement de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux ce qui est évidemment
inacceptable toute forme de harcèlement
toute façon c'est inacceptable pour
n'importe quelle raison c'est scandaleux
alors déferlement de haine sur les
réseaux sociaux on critique son
apparence physique et surtout son
orientation sexuelle vous rappeler lors
des Victoires de la musique elle avait
embrassé sa compagne
oui mais c'est plus que ça c'est le
prochain album qui sort bientôt d'oshi
elle a participé elle a écrit des
chansons elle travaille bien avec elle
c'est sa compagne via que j'embrasse
très fort qui est une fille formidable
mais c'est surtout il y avait aussi eu
le petit lac et là le petit
tu l'appelles le plus petit
alors attends non Sophie non restons
dans le sujet ces attaques comme ça
homophobes insupportables mais oui
il avait en fait participer un petit peu
à ça alors non
certainement c'est une maladresse de sa
part je le souhaite je l'espère
j'essaye d'atténuer un peu le truc bah
voilà donc mais il avait quand même en
plus rajouté une couche donc elle est
tout le temps attaquée non seulement sur
son orientation sexuelle mais aussi sur
son physique et quand en plus on voit ce
genre de je sais pas sortie journaliste
parce qu'il fait mais en tout cas qui
peut qui se permet non mais qui se
permet ce genre de remarque franchement
c'est voilà enfin je trouve ça
lamentable quoi de sa part de dire que
en fait les chanteuses doivent être
jeunes minces hétéros blanches ça se
sublime
Florian
et en plus elle a même été attaqué
depuis que elle a elle s'est livrée sur
son orientation sexuelle etc elle est
attaquée sur tous les fronts et même sur
ces problèmes de santé elle a parlé de
ses problèmes d'audition parce qu'elle
est en train malheureusement de perdre
l'audition et elle sera probablement
sourde un jour et les tweets enfin les
menaces qu'elles reçoivent sont aussi
liées à ça les gens en profitent pour ce
pour se moquer d'elle et pour et pour
lui souhaiter le pire Bernard ça fait
combien de temps ici même
on arrête pas de parler de ça on
n'arrête pas de parler du harcèlement
sur les réseaux sociaux au-delà de
Fabien ou peu importe quel journaliste
qui va dire un truc comme ça de vraiment
des vrais insultes il y a des menaces de
morts on va pas les chercher et alors
est-ce qu'on peut faire dehors on va en
parler mais vous vous qui passez à la
télévision qui est connu je termine ok
passez à la télévision qui est connu
est-ce que vous vous êtes harcelé est-ce
que vous recevez des insultes après les
émissions comment ça se passe
longtemps ici bien sûr il y a des trucs
je veux même pas vous dire ce que c'est
c'est quand quand ton père quand ton
père et ta mère qu'on fête ton père a dû
pisser dans ta mère
allez je vous donne je vous donne
cette public que réagit je pourrais se
rendre compte de ce qu'on peut prendre
dans la sur mon poids non parlons pas
sur machin mais voilà après pardon mais
on fait un métier où on sait ne faisons
pas ce métier si on ne résiste pas aux
réseaux sociaux on ne regardons c'est
c'est le premier truc qu'on va dire aux
jeunes chanteurs ou jeunes comédiens
c'est est-ce que tu es prêt à assumer ça
parce que on n'est pas préparé on n'est
jamais préparé à ça
champion tu reçois de ça non parce qu'en
fait moi je fais pas très attention en
fait parce que je reçois donc on peut
tout dire déjà je sais pas utiliser non
mais en fait c'est parce qu'il y a des
artistes qui sont nés avec les réseaux
sociaux bien sûr moi je suis pas né avec
les réseaux sociaux je suis né avec mon
sport avec mes médailles et après il y a
la télé et là on passe à une nouvelle
génération qui sont les réseaux mais je
fais pas attention à ça je préfère
rencontrer les gens dans la rue et puis
il y en a jamais un qui m'a craché
dessus même si même pas retenu
moi je suis totalement d'accord avec le
fait qu'effectivement quand on est
exposé bah qu'on est beaucoup plus sujet
à recevoir ce genre de ce genre de
message et vous savez plus on ajoute en
fait des caractéristiques quand on est
une meuf noire et qui en a pas non plus
pléthore en télé quand on est une meuf
avec des grosses fesses et des grosses
cuisses et qui en a pas pété en télé moi
je reçois plein de choses aussi en
revanche j'aimerais nuancer ton propos
le lot ça voudrait dire en fait qu'on
reçoit des micro-agressions quotidiennes
et que qui faille se dire on est des
victimes des micro-agressions et on peut
pas se dire bah si vous n'êtes pas prêt
à être victime ne faites pas de télé tu
vois ce que je veux dire c'est comme une
meuf dans la rue on doit préparer vous à
ça faut se préparer et malheureusement
ça fait partie du cadre alors mais ce
n'est jamais normal justement être
jamais admis
de Hoshi que j'aime beaucoup qui est une
fille formidable elle a elle a porté
plainte contre au moins un harceleur il
y en a eu tellement alors il a il a eu 8
mois de prison dans 6 mois avec sursis
juste deux mois ferme en réalité voilà
cyber-harcèlement et homophobie voilà et
c'est condamnable évidemment légalement
le cas je peux vous dire qu'elle sort
elle sort un nouvel album les amis en
septembre ça je le dis parce que je l'ai
reçu il y a pas longtemps cœur parapluie
ça s'appelle elle a beaucoup de talents
et d'ailleurs elle a participé également
l'album de Patrick Bruel